[Musique]
que la chaleur idole
on l'air sous pieds de madame
on prend les sous les bananiers
[Musique]
alors si Marone veut dire en espagnol
retour à l'état sauvage et puis comme la
cime d'un arbre
il pourrait dire que c'est comme la cime
mon cheveu d'accord et que le NA Marone
dedans la Marone était ses femmes qui
avaient cette force cette force d'être
et aujourd'hui nous nous en tant que
femme dans notre quotidien qui prend
plusieurs visages on est cette
représentation de ces femmes là que
aujourd'hui il est difficile aujourd'hui
dans la musique de de mettre en avant en
vrai
mon joli petit coin
[Musique]
la vie est tranquille on a écrit des
morceaux où on parle de cette force
qu'on a reçu et qu'on promule au fur et
à mesure des entrées dans le groupe le
guitariste un côté
blues jazz avec ce il a ramené son ami
Enrico qui lui ramène ses percussions
africaines et brésiliennes donc là on
refait encore un mélange ensuite il y a
le batteur qui a le côté maloya
traditionnel et qui joue aussi de la
phobie donc tout ça ça s'est mélangé
avec Bruno maintenant qui fait aussi du
blues et le percussionniste suit aussi
pour pareil pour le pour le côté
traditionnel maloya traditionnel et les
congas donc on va en Amérique latine
avec tous nos influences ben on a réussi
sans limite sans frontière mentale dans
le style musical a créé chaque morceau
quelque chose qui nous ressemble tous et
en même temps à personne d'autre
[Musique]
si la montagne danse entière
si beau la mer en ville à
a besoin de l'eau
nourrissons racines jusqu'à son père
son sexe
[Musique]
nourrissons ainsi jusqu'à son cœur
on débute sous la salle verte et sous la
salle verte comme bien par le passé j'ai
pu accéder à aller au Sakifo c'est
l'endroit où vraiment nous nous
retrouvons les racines et nous
retrouvons cette vibration là et c'est
frissons dont nous nourrit à nous
nourrit le corps pour un bien-être en
fait ce sera chaud d'accord surprise on
s'attend pas à chaque chanson il y a un
rythme différente ça t'en passe que à ce
qu'on va jouer et surtout on va danser
on va vibrer voilà ce qu'on propose nous
les dans le cabaret ceux qui tient
mélangé je retrouve qui s'alloulé tant
de cabaret
tout qui t'y a mélangé retrouve qui ça
nous les dans le cabaret tous les nez
dans le cabaret tout étire mélangé je
retrouve qui ça nous les dons
[Musique]